wer regelmäßig unsere videos guckt der
kommt um ein thema nicht herum
space immer wieder berichten wir über
die neuesten raketen über satelliten
oder interplanetare missionen und immer
wieder stehen dabei zwei nationen im
fokus natürlich die usa und auch
russland das liegt vor allem daran dass
beide länder pioniere der raumfahrt sind
und für einen großteil des wissens über
das wir heute verfügen verantwortlich
sind
aber wie sieht es denn in den anderen
ländern aus immerhin ist die raumfahrt
in den letzten jahren auch für kleinere
organisationen erschwinglich geworden
ich habe euch mal auch patron nach eurer
meinung gefragt und ihr wolltet gerne
wissen was die raumfahrtprogramme der
anderen länder gerade machen und wie da
die pläne für die zukunft sind und die
ambitionen sind tatsächlich ziemlich
groß von der rückkehr zum mond bis zur
besiedlung des mars ist alles dabei und
wenn ihr auch in zukunft über themen
mitbestimmen wollt dann könnt ihr das
auch petri an machen und das hilft uns
wiederum solche videos häufiger und
besser zu machen
china hält gesteinsbrocken vom mond
[Musik]
mit einer intelligenten software ein
lincoln bekannt
offen
man kann
die ersten jahre der raumfahrt waren
geprägt durch den wettkampf zwischen
russland damals noch der sowjetunion und
den usa die sowjetunion schaffte es 1957
den ersten satelliten und 1961 den
ersten menschen ins weltall zu bringen
amerika liegt 1969 nacht und sorgte mit
der mondlandung durch apollo 11 für das
damals größte medienereignis überhaupt
danach wurde es aber erst mal wieder
ruhiger um den raumfahrt zweikampf und
andere nationen konnten mit einsteigen
was genau eine raumfahrtnation heute
ausmacht das lässt sich tatsächlich gar
nicht so genau definieren
die einen sagen es reicht ein eigener
satellit im weltall
die anderen sagen dass diese auch mit
einer eigenen rakete ins all geschickt
werden muss neben amerika und russland
haben aktuell 11 starten und die esa als
europäische weltraumorganisation die
möglichkeit eigens entwickelte raketen
ins all zu schießen was bemannte mission
angeht sieht es hingegen schon wieder
maus soweit ist neben den beiden big
playern bisher nur china diese drei
länder sind bisher auch übrigens die
einzigen die es geschafft haben war ich
also ohne absturz auf dem mond zu landen
und deswegen starten wir unsere liste
space in ländern die weder die usa noch
russland sind auch mit china
[Musik]
2003 startete mit yang liwei der erste
chinese mit einer spende 5 rakete in
richtung all das ist zwar ein gutes
stück später als juri gagarin und alan
shepard doch das soll nicht heißen dass
china in den letzten jahren nicht
ordentlich aufgeholt hat 2018 und 2009
10 konnte ich ihn ja sogar das erste mal
überhaupt mehr erfolgreiche starts
verbuchen als alle anderen ländern
das liegt vor allem daran dass china
seit 2010 immer mehr raketen ins all
bringt während die usa und russland die
eigenen staats im vergleich zur
hochphase des space race deutlich
zurückgefahren haben
und wenn man jetzt bedenkt dass 2020
gefühlt alle zwei wochen eine space
extrahierte gestartet ist um neues
darlings satelliten ins all zu bringen
dann ist es umso beeindruckender dass
china stand november auch da knapp die
nase vorn hat hinzu kommt dass china
2009 10 30 die change vier sonde auf der
erdabgewandten seite des mondes landen
konnte und am 24 november diesen jahres
ist mit der schenkt fünf direkt die
nächste mission gestartet
die konnte dann schon am 16 dezember
2020 das erste mal seit 1976 eine
bodenprobe vom mond zur erde
zurückbringen
mit tiangong-1 2011 und die anfang 2016
konnten außerdem gleich zwei eigene
raumstationen in der erdumlaufbahn
platziert werden und ab 2021 soll sogar
eine größere modulare raumstation gebaut
werden er endlich da es um die eigene
forschung im all voranzubringen
china selbst hat bereits 2018 die länder
der nato dazu aufgerufen sich mit an der
station zu beteiligen
es ist aber noch unsicher ob es zu einer
internationalen zusammenarbeit da kommen
wird wie auf der iss denn gerade von
seiten der usa gibt es einige
sicherheitsbedenken die bisher auch
dafür gesorgt haben dass chinesische
astronauten nicht die iss besuchen
dürfen
für die zukunft plant china neben der
neuen raumstation auch die erforschung
von mond und mars so soll nach der
erfolgreichen schenk fünf missionen bis
2030 eine bemannte forschungsstation auf
dem mond errichtet werden und im juli
2020 ist mit der trend 1 mission 1
erster orbiter in richtung mars
gestartet der soll dort einen länder
absetzen indem sich ein mars rover
befindet der den boden des roten
planeten erkunden soll
und währenddessen soll die sonde weiter
großflächig informationen über
die oberfläche sammeln so viel zu china
und übrigens schon mal sorry für alle
namentlich gerade falsch ausgesprochen
habe zugegeben jetzt kommt in gewisser
weise kein einzelnes land sondern ein
verbund an ländern der european space
agency gehören aktuell 22 staaten an die
ihre mittel gemeinsamen bündeln
die esa wurde 1975 in paris gegründet
und hat auch noch heute dort ihren sitz
das europäische
satellitenkontrollzentrum und das
europäische astronautenzentrum befinden
sich aber in darmstadt und in köln
die esa hat ihren fokus in der
vergangenheit hauptsächlich auf den
start von satelliten und die erkundung
unseres sonnensystems gelegt das
flaggschiff der esa die seit 1979
gebauten trägerrakete ariane war lange
zeit die sicherste trägerrakete weltweit
aktuell wird an der ariane 6 gearbeitet
die ab 2021 starten könnte darüber
hinaus wird aktuell zusammen mit amerika
und kanada
der für 2021 geplante nachfolger des
hubble weltraumteleskops entwickelt das
james webb weltraumteleskop bei beiden
sachen bin ich mir allerdings nicht
sicher ob die 2021 wirklich kommen
werden
fingers crossed und der jupiter siemens
explorer kurz wise soll dann 2022 sogar
bis zum jupiter fliegen um auf seinen
monden nach wasservorkommen und nach
spuren außerirdischen lebens zu suchen
das sind natürlich bei weitem noch nicht
alle projekte an denen die esa
mitarbeitet aber alle aufzuführen würde
einfach die grenzen dieses videos hier
sprengen deswegen überlegen wir ein
eigenes video zu machen wenn ihr das
sehen wollt schreibt mir das gerne mal
unten in die kommentare
einfach nur ein ganzes video über die
esa wurde durch das interessieren würde
mich dann gerne machen
okay was china und europa bisher so
geschafft haben ist schon ziemlich
beeindruckend aber man muss auch dazu
sagen dass die budgets hierzu den
höchsten gehören weltweit zwei länder
die in den vergangenen jahren mit
geringerem budget ähnlich große dinge
vor hatten sind indien und israel
sie beide gehören nämlich zum klub der
die versucht haben auf dem mond zu
landen
und dieser club besteht aktuell aus nur
fünf ländern
leider ist es in diesen beiden fällen
nur bei dem versuch geblieben trotzdem
lohnt es sich natürlich diese länder mal
genauer zu betrachten
die usa die indian space research
organisation schießt seit 1980
regelmäßig satelliten und raumsonden ins
weltall
die drei höhepunkte der usa auf waren
zum einen die beiden chandrayaan
missionen und die manga lian mission
chandrayaan-1 handelt es sich um eine
sonde der erst 2008 gelang
wasservorkommen auf dem mond
nachzuweisen
eigentlich sollte sie dort länger
kreisen stürzte jedoch bereits 300 zwölf
tage nach dem start auf den mond mit der
chandrayaan zwei sonde sollte dann
2009/10 ein mitgeführtes lande module
auf der mondoberfläche aussetzen auch
das stützt jedoch bei dem versuch ab in
der zwischenzeit beschaffte ist die ice
euro 2013
aber mit der manga jahren noch viel
weiter es gelangt die sonde im orbit des
mars zu stationieren was vorher nur den
usa russland und der esa gelungen ist
und das hat ganz nebenbei nur einen
bruchteil dessen gekostet was die usa
für die maven mars mission demselben
jahr ausgegeben hat und was viele leute
auch schon erkannt haben
es hat tatsächlich weniger kostet als
dem film gravity zu schießen
die bemannte raumfahrt aber hatten in
dem bis jetzt noch keine große rolle
gespielt mit ragna war bis heute erst
ein inder im weltall und das war schon
1984 im zuge einer russischen mission
aktuell ist jedoch schon für das ende
von 2021 der nächste schritt geplant
dann will die usa das erste mal selbst
drei menschen in die erdumlaufbahn
befördern sollte die mission erfolgreich
sein dann will man bis 2030 in die
vollen gehen und hat sogar schon eine
eigene raumstation angekündigt
wie indien ist auch israel in den
letzten jahren immer weiter ins
satellitengeschäft eingestiegen und
genau so hat sich auch israel 2009 10 an
einer landung auf dem mond versucht hier
behandelt er sich übrigens auch um den
ersten privat finanzierten landeversuch
auf dem mond aber leider war eben auch
hier das ergebnis dasselbe wie bei dem
indischen versuch die vom
südafrikanischen milliardär ist kann
finanzierte und von der unabhängigen
organisation spacex entwickelte sonde
berät sollte eigentlich weich auf der
mondoberfläche landen
da es aber probleme mit dem hauptantrieb
gab konnte die sonde nicht abbremsen und
stürzte unkontrolliert ab aber auch in
israel will man die erfahrungen nutzen
und es werden bereits die nächsten
schritte geplant
das unternehmen israel aerospace
industries hat vor in der zukunft enger
mit der esa dem dlr und privaten
deutschen raumfahrtunternehmen
zusammenzuarbeiten
dabei wird unter anderem überlegt
gemeinsam an einem weiteren luna lernt
oder sogar einem mondfahrzeug zu
arbeiten
ein land das war noch nicht versucht hat
auf dem mond zu landen aber an anderer
stelle ein gutes stück weiter gekommen
ist ist japan die japanische
weltraumorganisation laxer konnte 2010
durch die erste erfolgreiche von einem
asteroiden zur erde gebracht im
bodenprobe für aufsehen sorgen
die reise der raumsonde hayabusa begann
bereits sieben jahre vorher im mai 2003
die nachfolge mission hayabusa 2
startete im dezember 2014 und konnte
ebenfalls erfolgreich proben von einem
asteoriden entnehmen die sie am sechsten
dezember 2020 also jetzt gerade erst
quasi im vorbeiflug auf der erde
abgeworfen hat mit an bord war übrigens
auch ein vom dlr entwickelter länder
namens mehr scott der auf dem asteroiden
abgesetzt wurde und dort 17 stunden lang
daten sammelte die sonne selbst ist
bereits auf der nächsten mission bei der
sie in elf jahren auf einem weiteren
asteoriden proben entnehmen soll
und irgendwie scheint es dann am ende
doch alle auf den mond zu ziehen in
japan arbeitet man nämlich seit 2009 10
zusammen mit toyota daran einen mond bus
zu entwickeln indem sollen sich bis zu
vier astronauten aufhalten können ohne
raumanzüge tragen zu müssen bis 2029
soll der mond rover entstehen und den
astronauten die möglichkeit geben die
oberfläche des mondes zu erkunden
durch einen brennstoffzellenantrieb soll
er außerdem in der lage sein bis zu
10.000 km zurückzulegen das reicht von
fact fast um den mond einmal zu umrunden
springen wir nun vom mond zum mars denn
wie ich in diesem video hier bereits
erwähnt habe planen die vereinigten
arabischen emirate bis 2100 17
eine dauerhafte maß basis zu errichten
in der menschen leben sollen
ein ambitioniertes ziel auch wenn sie
dafür 100 jahre zeit haben aber der
erste schritt ist immerhin schon getan
im juli 2020 wurde mit hilfe einer
japanischen trägerrakete die raumsonde
hob ins all gebracht und befindet sich
nun auf dem weg zum mars nach der
geplanten ankunft im februar 2021 soll
sie dort langfristig infos über das
klima der marsatmosphäre sammeln und von
hier müssen wir dann auch schon wieder
den sprung vom mars zurück zum mond
machen denn im september verkündete der
emiratische vizepräsident via twitter
dass 2024 die erste eigene mond-mission
inklusive eines eigenen mond rovers
starten soll
irgendwie wollen gerade alle zum mond
ist wie in den 60er jahren gerade ich
würde jetzt natürlich auch noch die
artemis mission erwähnen aber dieses
jahr von den usa und außerdem machen wir
zu den artemis missionen auch nochmal
eigene videos übrigens wenn ihr euch
fragt wem der mond eigentlich gehört da
kann ich euch nur die debatte ans herz
legen die debatte wird von der
gemeinnützigen organisation wissenschaft
im dialog gemeinsam mit der technischen
universität braunschweig betrieben und
sucht sich immer spannende
gesellschaftliche fragen raus um dort
wissenschaftliche fakten und
perspektiven einzubringen und dieses
video hier ist in kooperation mit der
debatte entstanden denn aktuell geht es
genau um solche fragen der weltraum
nutzung zum beispiel gibt es sehr viele
firmen didier liebend gerne ein stück
vom mond verkaufen wollen aber rechtlich
gültig ist das dann nicht
außerdem geht es um die frage wie
asteroiden in zukunft als rohstoffquelle
dienen könnten und auf uns ein krieg im
weltall droht ein echter star wars
fred cool ist es aber tatsächlich
überhaupt nicht denn immer mehr staaten
militarisieren gerade den weltraum
obwohl der weltraum vertrag von 1967
eigentlich festlegt dass keine
staatlichen souveränitätsrechte im
weltraum begründet werden dürfen und
dass das forschungs und nutzungs
freiheit geben soll
sehr spannende themen mit vielen
artikeln ich wahrlich die website auf
jeden fall unten in der video
beschreibung ein land dass man im
modernen space race wahrscheinlich
überhaupt nicht auf dem schirm hatte ist
luxemburg trotzdem hat man sich hier
einiges vorgenommen denn luxemburg wir
quasi das weltweite zentrum für
asteroiden pharma werden
bereits 2016 wurden die ersten
initiativen vorgestellt nachdem das land
dann 2017 das erste europäische gesetz
für den abbau von rohstoffen im all
festlegen konnte kam 2020 schon der
nächste große schritt in zusammenarbeit
mit der esa soll in luxemburg das
european space resources innovation
center entstehen
darin sollen die möglichkeiten der
förderung von ressourcen aus dem weltall
erforscht und entwickelt werden
und natürlich sollen auch private firmen
das zentrum als anlaufstelle für
kooperationen wahrnehmen
das alles ist ein ziemlich smart move
wenn man bedenkt dass sie in den
nächsten jahrzehnten ein riesiger
milliardenschwerer markt entstehen
könnte damit in drin zu sitzen könnte
luxemburg viele neue möglichkeiten
eröffnen
und das ist glaube ich auch schon ein
ganz guter schlusspunkt die
privatisierung der raumfahrt habe ich
auch schon mal in diesem video hier
angesprochen nicht nur in amerika haben
firmen wie spacex oder blue origin große
ambitionen auch am beispiel von space in
israel sieht man dass expeditionen ins
weltall nicht mehr ausschließlich
ländersache sind
doch auch abgesehen davon fällt auf dass
immer mehr internationale kooperationen
entstehen so konnte zum beispiel ende
2009 10 mit hilfe von china der erste
äthiopische satellit ins all starten
trotzdem sieht man am beispiel von
luxemburg dass jedes land so ein
bisschen seine eigenen schwerpunkte hat
während des israel und japan auf den
mond zieht wollen china und indien auf
lange sicht auch ihre eigene präsenz im
erd orbit durch forschungsstationen
erweitern noch weiter zieht es dann die
vereinigten arabischen emirate mit dem
plan einer mars kolonie und die esa mit
der expedition quer durch unser
sonnensystem
aber was sagt ihr dazu welche länder
haben eure meinung nach das
vielversprechendste raumfahrt
und glaubt ihr dass diese ganzen
ambitionierten ziele auch wirklich so
umgesetzt werden können schreibt mir
gerne unten in die kommentare
lasst uns darüber diskutieren ansonsten
wie mal vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig patrick